foreign
Google protects some of the largest web
properties in the world using the vast
security knowledge and experience gained
Google build security Command Center SCC
our built-in security and risk
management solution for Google Cloud
customers SCC helps customers manage
cyber risks by detecting software
vulnerabilities with configurations and
threats to their Cloud resources
now SEC is taking it one step further
and integrating attack path simulation
to help identify where organizations are
most vulnerable to attack as Cloud
environments scale security teams often
struggle to understand where their
biggest risks are and where to focus
their security efforts it's not easy to
know which issues create the greatest
security exposures
add to this a chronic shortage of
security resources and skills and the
need to focus on the right issues
becomes even more urgent
organizations need to rapidly identify
what security findings create the most
risk quantify that risk and enable drill
down into details and then take targeted
actions to remediate the risk sec's
attack pad simulation works by
dynamically analyzing the Assets in a
Google Cloud environment it considers
the relationships between the assets the
current defense is implemented and
potential security issues including
misconfigurations and vulnerabilities
additionally it considers some known
unknowns such as the risk of users
getting fished or risks of credentials
leaking among other things it uses this
information to automatically generate a
comprehensive graph model of your Google
Cloud environment the simulation engine
then functions from an external
attacker's point of view simulating
multiple attack methods across all known
paths to valued assets with the goal of
reaching and compromising those assets
revealing to you how an attacker could
compromise critical Cloud Resources with
this information SEC is then able to
provide insights into exposures and the
best actions to take to mitigate these
risks it's important to note that all of
the simulations are conducted on the
models so they don't introduce any risk
to your live environment
here we are in security Command Center
in the findings tab looking at
misconfigurations and vulnerabilities
detected
the question is which of these findings
do we prioritize first for this exact
use case here are the insights from the
attack path simulations
you can sort on attack exposure score to
identify what findings constitute the
highest risk in terms of exposing
valuable resources to potential
attackers
for this demo we set up a small
environment with some leaked credentials
we have now sorted on attack exposure
score and at the top of the list we see
an open SSH Port finding
we click on the score and get attack
path insights
here we can see that the open SSH Port
exposes four valued resources
we can click on instance 1 and see the
attack path details for that valued
resource
we see that from the public internet
there are three firewall rules that
allow access to instance one if we
expand on instance 1 we can see that
there are two tracks that need to be
accomplished Network connect and login
the attacker can use the openssh port in
combination with the leaked SSH key
since this SSH key is defined on the
compute engine instance configuration
the key provides pseudo privileges thus
leading to full access to instance 1.
going back to the list of findings the
third finding in the list is an admin
service account let's click into this
finding and look at the attack path
details there are three valued resources
exposed we'll explore the attack path
details for instance 3.
the first part of this attack path is
the same one that we saw before allowing
the attacker to gain access to instance
1.
from instance 1 the user can log into
instance 2 due to the IAM configurations
gaining access to the service account
with the admin service account finding
we just clicked into
this finding allows the user to log in
as an admin to any instance that is
configured to accept it among these
instances is instance 3 our valued
resource that the attacker now has admin
access to
once again at our findings list we can
see that there are some findings that
have an attack exposure score of zero
this means that in the simulation either
the attacker is not able to reach the
finding or the attacker is able to reach
the finding but from there they're not
able to reach and compromise any valued
resources so in summary attack exposure
scores provide insights on what to
prioritize you can click each one of
these scores and find attack paths and
driving factors behind the score
now you know how security Command Center
uses large-scale attack path simulations
running in the background to help you
keep your Google Cloud environment safer
enabling you to focus your scarce time
on what matters most to your security
make sure to check the description for
links to learn more about security
command center with attack path
simulation
[Music]